in preparing for a race Jill ran half
Jill ran half the distance that Sam ran
so let me write that down so let's say J
is the distance Jill ran it is equal to
half the distance will say s is the
distance that Sam ran and Sam ran three
times the distance that Aishah ran so
Sam
ran three times the distance that will
use a for the distance that I so ran
what was the ratio of the distance that
Jill ran to the distance that Aishah ran
so let's think about it so here we have
the we have how much Jill ran in terms
of s so maybe we can write how much ice
or ice ax ran in terms of s and then we
could find the ratio and then the esses
should cancel out so let's see over here
if we want to solve for if we want to if
we want to write this so we have how
much I show ran in terms of how much Sam
ran we can just divide both sides by
three so you divide both sides by three
we're left with Aishah
ran 1/3 the distance Sam ran so if you
want to find the ratio the ratio of the
distance Jill ran to the distance I see
I ran so it's the ratio J over a the
ratio J over a this is going to be equal
to 1/2 s that's what J is equal to over
1/3 s that's what a is equal to over 1/3
s so it's equal to 1/2 divided by 1/3
the S is cancel out the S is cancel out
so this is going to be equal to 1/2 when
you divide by 1/3 that's the same thing
as multiplying by 3 over 1 and so 1
times 3 is 3 2 times 1 is 2 so the ratio
is equal to so the ratio that this is
the Jill ran to the distance that I show
ran is 3 to 2 or 3 halves